hey everybody thank you for being here
at NDC Copenhagen we're gonna talk about
application security today and how to
address it from a standard point of view
we're gonna look at a SBS standard for
point 0.1 we're gonna talk about why
it's important why it matters we're
gonna talk about why it's changed and
we're gonna look at ways that you can
use it effectively in software
development to help to help you do
security better right
who here is God who here is doing
software development who can say
I got security all figured out no
problem we're all we're all set on
security here at the software company
and that's nobody because it's still an
emerging topic that everybody struggles
with no one's innocent here right kind
of like the corona virus you know it's
like it's the great equalizer
information security my name is Jim I'm
gonna be your speaker for this section
I'm a former board member the OS
foundation I work on the several OS
projects like the cheat sheet series and
the standard the ASVs standard and one
of them I'm one of the authors of it
then coding for a long time I live in
Hawaii I live in Virginia right now I'm
in Virginia stored up in rural Virginia
with a lot of food supplies guns and
ammo and the hope that we don't
degenerate into rioting and looting
across the world we'll see we'll see and
I hope no I really hope that you don't
lose any loved ones but this is good a
lot of people are gonna get hurt by this
and the song of the day is don't fear
the reaper it's gonna hit us all no one
gets out of this alive alright that side
let's talk about security enough about
the news of the day look at this email
address this is a valid email address
that is gonna be it's gonna be accepted
by your validation layer it's a legal
email address you can email me at but
it's a sequel injection payload so the
point is even valid data can cause
injection I digress here's the OWASP top
10 these are the top
security risks it's a publication that a
wasp pushes out every three years or so
it's a very famous list these are the
top ten security issues of the day and a
lot of standards cite this top 10 list
in particular the payment card
industry's data security standard they
cite the OWASP top 10 here as part of
that standard I kind of think this is a
bad idea anyways these are some of the
new categories they're talking about
proper logging a very specific issue
like xxe and xml security issue and
insecurity serialization what are the
newer topics in the world of web
security the point is this is not an
organized list it's ten kind of random
topics some are high-level topics like
authentication some are specific like
xxe you don't want to base a security
program off this this o wass top 10 you
want to read it once you want to enjoy
it once and use it to learn but then go
to something else and let let's take a
step back here when we look at an
application security program there's a
lot of practices that security
professionals in my industry will talk
about and my industry is application
security it's the security of building
secure software and testing software for
security there's all these things we
recommend from security unit testing
DevOps automation of security testing
planning sprint assistance for security
all these I'm gonna hammer in on this
whole idea of a security checklist this
is how AAS ves started and ASVs stands
for the application security
verification standard this is a
documentation project from the OWASP
open source nonprofit foundation when
this project first started as a basic
checklist of some of the top things you
can do in terms of requirements for
secure development and it was not really
meant to be a standard it was just a
bunch of leading practices and what this
really is is this is the wasds that
we're talking about this is
web application and API application
application security verification
standard since this standard was
published other sub standards have also
been released like the mobile
application security verification
standard the IOT application security
verification standard so we're gonna
focus on the web version of ASDs the
original version of this standard and by
the way the latest version 4.0 point 1
the world the four Oh Virgin this was
done in github and we took open comments
from the world to to triage and to
clarify and to fix the requirement list
that we built for this standard so it
wasn't done in a closed room you know
with a secret cabal it was done out in
the open where community comments were
welcomed and any standard that doesn't
do that
buff ANBU do that too standard I would
say to Italian all right so this is the
standard this is the essential part of
the standard a list of requirements each
requirement is going to be granular like
look at this verify that the user
passwords are at least 12 characters in
length
that's our minimum rec recommendation
for password length and every app should
do this level one two and three level
one says love level so at level one two
and three the lowest level says every
app to do this a level above that is for
like apps but sensitive data and the
highest level is like infrastructure
apps apps let's shoot missiles or stuff
like that really high-end infrastructure
or billions of Records so three levels
of severity to consider for these
requirements and and you lose involved a
lot of people right I'm one of the
authors that was originally worked on by
Jeff Williams Dave Ricker's and Mike
Barsky were some of the original authors
of it this is the current team working
on the latest couple of versions Andrew
Vander stock is the spiritual leader and
he's really the main thrust here the
annual customer twitter out to the
beginning a great helper i've been
working on the last two versions josh
Grossman and Mark in eBay were the three
big volunteers who helped the latest
version did the majority of the work
and lot of reviewers out there like Ron
Paris MP Emmer and Adam Claude hill and
lots of real smart people jumped in
smarter than us to help clarify our
requirements this is what makes it great
now what we changed in the 4.0 version
is to make the actual like artifacts
behind the standard more useful so
everything's in markdown it's just
there's a script that we can use to
generate a version of this in any kind
of file format so the the raw standard
itself is usable by teens so that I
think that's important it's comunist 853
compliance that's the that is the
digital authentication guideline from
the US government and they released a
new identity guideline out like last
year that was mind-boggling and how
awesome it was and well-written it was
and you know you don't have to follow
our standard you can swap out the
authentication requirements for your
European standards so I know you have
specific standards around banking using
digital certificates there's no reason
why you can't swap out sections for your
own standards also you know we had an
IOT section but IOT is not specifically
web IOT is its own thing so we ripped
out all the IOT requirements that were
newly written for 4.0 and instead of
adding it to the 4.0 standard we just
did a preview appendix chapter so the
requirements are there but they're not
being mixed in with web these are first
different teams should have different
requirements based on your architecture
we also change your requirements to
address for real what a modern web
application is full support for things
like lambdas and containers a lot more
requirements in the world of API since
they've taken off more thick more
requirements around Dom XSS and jump
since javascript clients are are in
vogue these days and similar we have
those requirements augmented in the
latest version we also Maps the
requirements to cwe's but let's talk
about cwe cwe's it's the common weakness
of numeration a list of weaknesses from
mitre
it's a standard in the world of security
and a very important one
let's talk about this ASVs the standard
that we've written this is about
controls for Web Apps and weaknesses are
not controls there's no way to make a
clean mapping and the mapping doesn't
even make sense but we got asked to do
it so many times that we just did it to
shut people up so we can move on with
our lives that's the truth
so it's an imperfect mapping it's ugly
and not every item has a cwe but we did
it check the box that box is checked we
did it so what's changed everything we
remembered everything from scratch okay
this is not exciting but it's important
the numbering matters because we
aversion one we have requirements a 1 2
& 3 then for version 2 removes a second
requirement now we have requirement 1 &
3 & 5 & 6 so after several versions we
have requirement 1 3 9 11 a lot of a lot
of gaps so a version requirement a ASVs
4 we wipe the slate clean and we and we
could we'd wipe the slate clean and
renumber and everything from scratch new
can pave baby you know like we're seeing
right now so each section is reorganized
and reordered we got rid of a lot of
duplications and l1 is the new minimum
we say l1 are the require any
requirement flagged as l1 and again this
is required this standard is just a list
of about 300 or so requirements that's
the whole standard that's the guts the
guts of this l1 our requirements that
every action follow remember every
standard every requirement is flagged as
l1 l2 or l3 and l1 is every app that's
the new minimum all of level one should
be testable by your pen testers it's the
only level that's easily testable and
you should be doing hybrid reviews with
the combination of a penitent
penetration tester by a security expert
and using a variety of scanning tools to
augment that work
and by the way DevOps is about scanning
like a hundred times a day I digress so
we also added in the PCI requirements we
didn't like to do this it's not super
web-centric but it's needed for PCI
support because we're trying to help
place the OWASP top 10 in pci so we want
to make PCI happy so they get rid of the
OWASP top 10 out of PCI and use a SBS
instead so we included buffer overflows
integer and say string operations and
other things to ensure PCI compliance
within our standard they don't they're
not perfect maps to the standard but we
made PCI happy and that's a big win um
what's gone the mobile chapters removed
mobiles out mobile has its own standard
than mobile ASVs
the iot chapter pushed to the appendix
any defense that was one browser or one
language only we got rid of it and
things that weren't that important that
were debatable we got rid of it so we're
cleaning house we're cleaning it up so
here's the ASVs detail so section i'm
not gonna talk about every requirement
there's 300 requirements or so so i'm
gonna talk about the categories and then
we'll finish up here
so level so level of category one
architecture this is about like the
design of your app and more high-level
issues um we talked about the need for
process like a secure software the
moment lifecycle we talked about the
need for security review like threat
modeling and we talked about the idea
just the general requirements that you
have to build security in from day one
at the design and architectural
conception so it's like security is
intentional so the thing that you build
not something you slap on at the end we
don't do this for it's not level 1 it's
for level 2 and 3 apps only for high
high-risk risky apps high sensitive data
and similar level to a category 2 is
authentication identity we align this
again with NIST 863 except for passwords
this says to use 8 character passwords
but fungo you like character password we
do 12 character passwords at the ASVs
that's level 2 so credential life cycle
from issuance to retirement we we talked
about credential construction protection
we talked about new attack attack
categories like credential stuffing and
how to store a pass
Fido and multifactor so it's a modern
set of requirements to give developers
proper guidance level 3 session
management the big change there is we
talked about adding jots to your world
JSON web tokens JSON web tokens are the
main artifacts used for stateless
session management when you primarily
for stateless api's that's a big
departure from web app session
management that we had in days gone by
so category 4 of the ASDs standard if
you just got here hello you're late but
if you just got here we're talking about
the OWASP application security
verification standard a list of security
requirements for developers and web
development we're looking at the
different categories right now because
you're late this is kind of going for
this covers API access control security
which is a bit different than web app
security like map and Olaf the mapping
to arrest design and and we cover
serverless TechEd here as well which is
a little different the way we design
access control in similar layers level 5
is about like basic data handling you
validate you sanitize it you're in code
when you're trying to use data when you
have data that you have from a user or
any variable frankly but primarily users
are untrusted data data that the
attacker can modify you got to validate
it or you have to sanitize it or encode
it before you use it depending on what
you're doing with it and explaining this
is important we also and this is all
about user interface security primarily
but also issues like injection
prevention validate validating URLs to
stop server side request forgery and
proper configuration for things like -
serialization attacks are just not doing
it design stuff so major revamp of this
section that talks about data handling
for user interface stuff like you
validate if it's a URL I'm putting into
a form tag for the action I want to
validate to make sure that URL is not a
JavaScript URL or similar if I'm letting
the users submit HTML that I'm gonna
render for another user like you a
WYSIWYG editor I want to run that
through an HTML sanitizer that's
and if I want to display data exactly
like a user typed it in in a web page
I want to encode you some kind of
escaping there's a quick blip on what
those three controls are about story
cryptography we the big change there is
using modern key management mechanisms
and key stores level six error handling
we we talked about being careful not to
leak sensitive information and errors we
talked about proper logging error
handling is boring I like it it's
important but I'm gonna move on I move
on v8 data protection like encryption in
transit sensitive data protection around
gdpr and California laws and how to
properly store data client-side and what
the risks are with that like local
storage
I can hack me some local storage
cross-site scripting if I can inject
JavaScript into your website I could
steal all the data from local storage
it's terrible v9 communication security
so v8 is data protection more around
protecting data at storage so and I
slipped up there a bit it's just a data
storage security where v9 is
communication security mostly most most
importantly proper HTTPS Everywhere
configured properly category tens about
malicious code things like Easter eggs
and backdoors and similar that's it's
usually a level three issue category 11
business logic you know something as
simple as a step abuse attack where
suppose you have an e-commerce website
where I add items to a shopping cart I
check out and my address add my payment
information and then complete the
checkout if I can skip by hard-coding
the URL and add to my shopping cart then
skip to the checkout step and just check
out without paying that's an abuse of
business logic common problems hard to
find files and resources we're fixing
things like remote file inclusion
primarily and in and out and file upload
download security and just file i/o as
we mix that
with user requests and user input and
get real tricky we cover all that in
this section level 13 category 13 is a
complete revamp right it's a complete
revamp API security addressing restful
stuff addressing new things like graph
QL it's a whole party v14 configuration
primarily to address the cloud and and
modern deployment mechanisms like and
it's the same old stuff it's just a
different way to configure it some
really unique things you got to get
right on pushing stuff to the cloud and
very often we see less professional
administrators and more developers
managing these things which is good and
bad bad if you know the skills good in
in that we have less we have more power
we give to the developer to get stuff
done so all the configuration stuff is
there now our recommendation is again
you don't just use ASVs out-of-the-box
what I recommend you do is you fork it
specific for your company let developers
make the final decisions around what
requirements you're going to keep so
they own it so they do it and you can
modify your fork of the standard over
time as you want to augment the work
that you're doing or if you're go to use
ASVs
out-of-the-box as is start with level
one and for every app and work your way
up to level two and level three for for
the more sensitive apps within your
organization you can it's free you know
the 4.0 point one was released last year
so it's been around for a year already
there's wiki and github if you're
opinionated and don't like our comment I
don't like our requirements I applaud
your intellect please go to github and
give us comments under the 4.0 point one
branch it's all it's on the wiki all our
contact informations on the wiki and if
you have questions for me
I'm Jim at a loss org I'm also at gym at
mana code calm my day job I'm really
happy you're here at NDC Copenhagen to
learn more about software development I
hope you download
and read and review all of the ASVs
requirements to teach you more about
application security while you're going
through it if you have any questions and
one of the authors just drop me a note
I'm always happy to answer questions
you're great you're awesome I'm done
with this talk you have a wonderful day
and don't forget don't fear the reaper I
weep for those we lose I do and it may
hit you but you know just keep charging
learn about security learn more about
development master the art while you're
hidden away at home master the art of
software engineering even more I have a
great time out there thank you so much
everybody
you